[MUSIC PLAYING]
DOMINIC PREUSS: My
name is Dominic Preuss,
and I'm here with
Dave Nettleton,
and we're going be
speaking about where
to store your data on the
Google Cloud platform.
So before we do any sessions,
I like to set expectations.
If this isn't what
you're looking for,
feel free to go find
another session.
I won't be offended.
We're going to go through just
a quick background of storage
services to give you a
little bit of context.
We're going to go through
some concrete examples of how
customers use our
products to give you
a little bit of reference
architecture for how
our products are used together.
One of the things that
is always apparent to us
is that you never
use a single product.
You're always using multiple
products to make a solution.
So it's useful to understand
how we put these things together
to build those solutions.
And the last one is to
give you a decision tree
to help you decide
which product to use.
We spend lots of time explaining
to customers the portfolio,
and sometimes it's
just really helpful
to have a set of
questions that'll
get you to the right answer.
So we provided a very high-level
one to help direct you.
Dave is going to start by
going through some background.
DAVE NETTLETON: Hi, everybody.
Thank you.
Dave Nettleton.
So I've been working in the
space of data and analytics
for probably some 15 years now.
So I just sort of
wanted to walk you
through a little bit of some
of the changes in the use cases
and the patterns
and the technologies
that we've seen in
that time, and just
use that as a way to sort of
map to some of the technology
that you see coming
from GCP today.
You know, I've used a
slide like this in one form
or another for the last,
I guess, five or 10 years,
and it constantly,
kind of, blows
my mind to see the
kinds of things
that customers are
looking to do with data,
and the analytics that
they can generate off that.
And literally, you know, it's
transforming industries in ways
that perhaps people
didn't even think
about five or 10 years ago.
I've spent a lot of time
talking with customers,
and there's been this real
change where technologies,
new capabilities, and
the cloud are really
helping people think
about how to not just run
their industries
more efficiently,
but actually really disrupt
them in very meaningful ways
and create new businesses.
One of my favorite examples
is in the airline industry.
So all those Rolls
Royce engines that you
see on airlines as you're
flying around the world
and looking out the window and
see the little RR letters--
they're not actually
owned by the airlines.
They're actually leased to
the airlines by Rolls Royce.
And, you know, the reason for
that is really interesting.
Rolls Royce realized that if
they can manage all of the data
and collect all the
telemetry from those engines,
do rich analytics on it,
do machine learning on it,
they can actually deliver
a much better experience
for their customers,
the airlines,
by ensuring that the engines
are better maintained
and that the airplanes
themselves remain up in the air
much longer.
So they gather huge amounts of
data, huge amounts of telemetry
from these engines.
They capture it, they
run analytics on it,
they do predictive
maintenance on it.
They don't, you
know, strip engines
down on regular
schedules, go check them,
and then put them all
back together again.
They're much more
able to tell when
they need to bring an engine
in for repair and maintenance.
All sorts of industries
are being transformed
by this amazing ability to
gather huge amounts of data
and do analytics on it.
So all industries,
many use cases,
amazing transformations
happening.
Let's talk a little bit,
though, about what that actually
means in reality when you are,
sort of, feet in the ground,
working in an
enterprise, and thinking
about I've got
some infrastructure
and now I need to think
about using the cloud
to take advantage of some of
the capabilities that it offers.
And I sort think of, like,
three main stages of journeys
that customers embark on.
Sometimes they're doing
these in parallel.
The first part is probably
like four or five years ago,
where organizations
were thinking, OK,
I've got my on-premises
infrastructure.
What I'm going to
do is I'm going
to use the cloud for
backup, for archival.
I'll continue to use it
through the application
that I have today.
I'm going to reduce
my operational cost.
I'm a bit worried
about security,
about networking,
but yeah, I'll sort of
dip my toe into the cloud
and I'll start to archive
and put some of my cold data
up in the cloud.
Or maybe I'm going to burst some
of my compute into the cloud
because I don't want to buy
some new capital infrastructure.
And so key areas of
GCP that matter there
are things like compute
storage, networking.
Security is very big-- ensuring
you have the networking
capabilities to
set up the security
that you need between your
on-premises infrastructure
and the cloud.
Sort of the second
step in the journey
is when organizations start
to think about actually
lifting and shifting significant
parts of their infrastructure
and running it in the cloud.
So control is in the cloud.
And here, you're
thinking about running
a much larger-scale
enterprise applications,
like scale-up databases,
running them in VMs.
You heard some of the
great announcements
this week about things like
having HANA running now in GCP,
and being able to just
really lift and shift
your infrastructure from
on-premise to the cloud,
and really start to think about
the cloud as the primary place
for running key parts
of your infrastructure.
Often that infrastructure
might look still
quite a lot like
what you've been
used to running
on premises, it's
just you're choosing to run and
operate it in a different way.
Also here, you're starting to
think about running much more
compute in the cloud.
A great example--
I worked with a
company that wanted
to do risk analysis for
all of their trade analysis
during the day.
So they'd gather large
amounts of data and telemetry
from their financial traders,
and for reporting purposes
that have to sort of understand
the risk in their portfolio.
So every evening, they'd run
large amounts of compute over
that data to understand their
risk portfolio to report
for compliance purposes.
And they were literally
faced with a choice
of should I buy a new physical
data center and provision it
with all the
hardware that I need,
or should I leverage the cloud
for the large amount of burst
compute that it can
give me over that data?
And as you start to
move in this direction,
you're starting to look for much
more managed infrastructure.
You don't want to be
managing one or two VMs--
OK, not too bad.
Setting up clusters
of thousands of VMs
for either compute or
for Hadoop is really
not a business that you
want to be in anymore,
and so there's a set of
managed capabilities that you
see in GCP now that let
you manage and operate
large amounts of compute and
analytics and data at scale.
And then there's
applications that
are just getting built net new.
So for cloud-native companies,
this is where they often start.
They don't have any
existing infrastructure
so they just start new.
And you get new
classes of applications
here for they, like, app
dev, web, mobile, et cetera,
but also new applications
for data in analytics.
And then you'll see a great
set of capabilities here
from, like, BigQuery,
machine learning, App Engine
to help you sort of build net
new capabilities in the cloud.
So these two slides--
I just want to set
up a lot of use cases
that we see that are very
exciting to do in the cloud,
and there's a lot of different
journeys to get there.
What I'll talk a
little bit about now
is a bit more of what's been
the evolution on the storage
and the data side.
So if we think a little bit
about the evolution of storage,
you know, you start with the
basic direct attached storage.
So physical disks attached
to a physical computer
sitting under a desk, right?
That's kind of the
classic initial wave
that we bound compute
storage and storage together.
That has steadily
evolved in enterprises
now to bringing in SANs and NAS.
And the key thing there
is this observation
that hey, look, if we
separate the compute
from the storage with
a network in between,
then that gives us flexibility.
We can better control how
we provision our storage.
we provision our compute.
We can set different policies
on performance, et cetera.
Let me ask-- how many of
you are today running SANs?
All right, a handful.
OK.
How many of you are running NAS?
So filers-- shed
filers in some way?
Yeah, OK.
A few more hands there, right?
So these are, like,
core building blocks
of enterprise
infrastructure that people
are used to using today.
And if you look at
what we have in GCP,
we have a set of capabilities
there to enable that.
So if you're just running
VMs with disks attached,
then we have Google Compute
Engine together with local SSD
or persistent desk, which
gives you a way to create a VM
and attach, effectively,
block storage to that.
Local SSD is
similar to DAS where
it's sort of local
to the machine,
whereas PD is more the data
is coming over the network.
How many people are running
on-premise object stores?
Wow, you've got the
whole lot, right?
Yeah, so object
storage is something
that came about a little
bit more recently.
We don't actually see a
lot of people running it
because most people now do their
object storage in the cloud,
but this is also
another way that people
have chosen to store typically
large, unstructured blobs
of data.
And we have a product, Google
Cloud Storage, for that.
So this has sort of
been a little bit
of the evolution of, kind of,
the core storage technology,
and the set of products that
we have to sort of meet you
where you are in evolving
those technologies
and applications to the cloud.
OK, let's switch over to
databases and analytics.
So, you know, I used to work
on a database product, a very
popular database
product, and I kind of
joked to the very
senior people who
I worked with who helped
create and build that product--
man, you guys had it
kind of easy, right?
Because everybody knows what a
traditional database is, right?
So for 30, 40 years, the
traditional database industry
was kind of easy--
"easy."
You had a traditional
database, you'd
could capture your transactional
data against the database
if you wanted to do reporting on
it you would use ETL to extract
data from the database,
transform it, and then load it
into a data warehouse.
You knew the questions
you wanted to answer like,
hey, what's the sales
by region or sales
by rep that I want to
look at every week?
So you knew that as you're
pulling the data out,
you could transform it
into a different, you know,
snowflake schema,
whatever schema you chose,
and then run your query and
reporting against that on,
like, a regularly scheduled
monthly, weekly basis, right?
And this was the world of data
and analytics for, you know,
20, 30 years.
The pattern was very,
very well-established.
Who knows this pattern?
All right.
OK, most hands so far.
Everyone, this is a really
well-established and
well-understood
enterprise pattern.
And Oracle, IBM, Microsoft
had great databases,
also great data warehouses.
Teradata and others provided
that infrastructure.
And then about 10 years ago,
kind of, all hell broke loose.
You know, there was
so much innovation
happening at the same time.
So big data started
to come along.
Hadoop came along.
The Hadoop vendors would say,
throw away our data warehouse.
You don't need it anymore.
Put all your data into Hadoop.
You need a place to
capture gigantic amounts
of unstructured data.
Data warehouses are not
cost-effective for that,
so where do you put it?
So Hadoop was a great place
to capture huge amounts
of unstructured data.
Then there's specialist forms of
stores that started to emerge.
Well, what happens if I don't
have really structured data
that I need to perform
particular transactions on,
and I can make compromises?
What happens if I want to
capture really large amounts
of data that I don't
really know necessarily
what the columns are that
are going to be over time?
Like IoT is a great scenario.
Cell towers are all always
generating cell data records
in terms of all the calls.
Different versions of the
software, different versions
of the vendors,
different versions
of the software on
the cell towers all
mean that there's no
single, well-formed piece
of transactional data
that's getting produced.
It's structured,
but there's a lot
of variation to that structure.
So where do I store that data?
Can I put it in a
traditional database?
No, that doesn't work.
Can I put it into a warehouse?
No, that doesn't work either.
So you started to see a set
of these sort of NoSQL stores
start to emerge around
two main patterns--
one for very wide databases
in terms of columns,
and then another in terms
of having much more,
sort of, hierarchy
and structure,
typically for capturing
things like JSON documents
and other things that
are very familiar
for mobile applications.
And then at the
far right there--
so actually, let
me back up a sec.
So this has caused, frankly,
a lot of confusion, right?
There's a lot of
new technologies
that are out there.
There's a lot of
people who are looking
to learn a lot of new techniques
and a lot of new patterns.
Not just ruining this in
terms of infrastructure
that they run themselves,
but also in the cloud.
And then at the far
end of that, we just
announced earlier
this month Spanner.
If you're wanting
to run databases
at really large
scale, the only way
you've been able
to do that to date
has just been to scale up and
up and up and up, and buy bigger
and bigger and bigger boxes.
But with Spanner now, that's
offering a really different
paradigm to really give
you a very effective way
to scale out and actually get
the scale and power of a really
large-scale database with
the simplicity of something
like Spanner.
And along the bottom there-- and
we'll go through these in more
detail--
I've put the set
of Google products
that are available in
GCP that are the products
that sort of help meet
you on that journey.
So actually, let's just
get another show of hands.
Who has a, sort of, traditional
relational database in a VM?
All right.
How many people
have data warehouses
that they're dealing with?
All right.
How many people are using
Hadoop and big data?
Wow, we've got
everybody here today.
How many people have used
a wide column database
in some shape or form?
OK, how about documents
stores, NoSQL stores?
All right.
How many people
have used Spanner?
I know you're from
Google, and [INAUDIBLE].
Great.
OK, so now we're going
to dive in a little bit
and we'll go through each of
these products in a little bit
more detail and talk about some
of the more specific use cases
that we see for them.
OK, so let's start off
first of all with storage.
So Google Cloud Storage is our
managed object storage service,
so this is for storing, you
know, objects in the cloud.
We offer it in four flavors--
multi-regional, regional,
nearline, and coldline.
Each of those pretty closely
aligns to key use cases
that we see around content
storage and delivery, analytics
and ML, and archival.
And I'll go through those each
in a little bit more detail.
One of the things that we
really love about this product
is that we provide a very
consistent API across all
the different storage classes.
So whether you want
to archive your data
or whether you
want to serve it up
from our most highly
available storage class,
you have the same API
to access that data
and you get the same
performance in terms
of millisecond latency,
time to first byte,
and in terms of throughput.
So this has actually
let us and our customers
do some really, really
interesting and innovative
things.
And, of course, we offer this
with a very high availability.
Now let's go through one of
those use cases in a little bit
more detail.
So content storage and delivery.
And, you know, this
is one area where
Google has been very deeply
invested for many years.
As I'm sure you've heard,
Google has several billion user
products.
Many of them require us to serve
content to them really, really,
really quickly, and so
we have an amazing set
of infrastructure in Google
that lets us do that.
And Google Cloud Storage
is only one part of that.
You know, Google Cloud Storage
sits on top of Google's, you
know, world-class
network infrastructure.
And if you were at the
keynote this morning,
you heard Urs talk a
little bit about that.
We carry a very large portion
of the world's network traffic
on our network, and that lets
us do amazing things like
invest very deeply
in really important
high-throughput connections,
do really great traffic
optimization, and serve
data really, really well,
and keep it on our
network to the closest
point to our customer.
So this example, content
storage and delivery.
If you take somebody
like, say, I'm
a company that has media files.
Let's say Vimeo--
serves and delivers
media content around the world.
Or you might have
a website where
you want to serve
content, or you just
have images that
you need to serve
as part of an application.
So with Google Cloud Storage,
you can store that data
and object storage and then
tier that data based on how hot
or not it is.
So typically, you might
store this in something
like multi-regional storage.
This stores the data
in two regions that
are more than 100
miles apart, so if we
happen to have a regional
outage for some reason or other,
data will still be served
from within another region
in that area.
You don't need to change
your application to failover
or anything like that.
We handle it all transparently.
And we'll serve content
through directly from that.
So multi-regional is
a great storage class
for that use case.
If you find that your
data is getting cold--
media files are a great
example, or movies
that get uploaded after.
And maybe they get used
for, like, a month or two
and they're popular,
but then maybe they
don't get touched for a while.
Well, you know, when
you're storing that data,
you know, that's still data that
people might want to access,
but you can't really take
it offline and put it in,
like, cheap storage
that's slow to access.
You still want to
have that ability
to access the data very quickly.
With Google Cloud
Storage, we let
you tier that data through
two storage classes
called nearline
and coldline that
let you basically
pay differently
for how you access the data.
So you might start out with
the data in multi-regional,
which is the most expensive,
most highly available.
But then as customers
use the data less,
you might tier it down or
something like coldline
where you pay much
less for storing it,
and the cost changes a
little bit to pay for access.
So gives a lot of flexibility
for how we do that.
The other great thing that we
do with Google Cloud Storage
is that there's
so much, actually,
that's included just
as part of the product,
it's kind of amazing.
Data is edge cache, so if you
store data in the US but you
consume it out of the UK, we
carry that data on our network
through to a POP that's as
close to you as possible--
often your ISP--
and egress the data there.
It's kind of like basic CDN
functionality for edge caching.
It's kind of built-in, right?
If you want to upload
data, again, we
don't upload over
the public internet.
We upload to our local POP
and then take it from there.
And then again,
there's consistent API
and consistent performance--
super valuable.
No matter what tier
of storage you're in,
you get the same performance.
The contract we want
with our application
is write your
application, and then
manage your data differently.
Your performance profile
for your application
won't change at all.
So as well as using just GCS
in its, kind of, raw form,
we also have both the cloud
CDN and great partnerships
with other CDN
providers, and these
help you have more
control over the caching
policies for your data,
where you peer your data,
when it peers, and
really sort of give you
extra flexibility
in how you build
and deliver applications here.
You saw this morning, also,
we have a great partnership
with Firebase, one of
our teams here at Google,
and making it really easy
for you to leverage something
like this for building
mobile applications.
OK, so that's content storage
and delivery for Cloud Storage.
OK, another use case
for Cloud Storage--
this is an analytics pipeline.
So here, you might want to
capture large amounts of data
from a number of different
sources for, say, marketing.
Maybe you're an e-commerce site.
You're capturing lots
of data, log data,
potentially, from
your machines that's
capturing usage of what
people have been doing.
You might want to capture
Facebook sentiment, Twitter
feeds, et cetera, so you
might have both data coming
in real time, as well as
data that you're pulling
in occasionally in batch mode.
And really, you
want a single place
to sort of drop all
that data and often
store it very cheaply.
Maybe you're not quite sure what
you want to do with the data
yet in the future,
and you just need
some place to drop the data
and store it for a long time.
I worked with one
company in the UK,
very large e-commerce site--
for two years, they spent
two years capturing data,
and they just dropped it into
the low-cost object storage.
They weren't sure what they
were going to do with it,
but they knew they
were going to need
to capture that
object, that raw data,
so that they could do
their analytics later.
So if you think you're
going to do analytics
and ML at some
point in the future,
start thinking about
gathering the data now.
And a super easy place to
drop and store that data
is somewhere like GCS--
very cheap.
You just pay for the
storage as you use it.
So something like the
regional storage class--
remember, we have
four storage classes--
multi-regional, regional,
nearline, coldline.
The regional storage class is
super interesting for this use
case because what that
does is it will effectively
keep your data within
a single region.
And the reason that's often
important in this use case
is you want to spin up
large amounts of analytics
and compute to operate
over that data.
Now, sure you could store
the data in multi-regional,
but then you're going to
pay a latency cost as we
go access that data for you.
So this lets you co-locate
storage and analytics
in a single region,
and then with that, you
can then start to spin up all of
the other great analytics tools
that we have in
the GCP portfolio.
So if you want to use
Hadoop, take a look
at something like Dataproc.
With Dataproc, you can spin
up a large Hadoop cluster,
pay for it and use it
only for when you need it,
bind it to the data that's in
GCS, and when you're finished,
shut it down.
So that's great for
doing batch analytics.
Cloud Dataflow-- super powerful
set of tools and capabilities
for running both streaming
and batch analytics.
Of course, you can
use machine learning.
Appoint machine
learning to this data.
And then the pattern
that we often see here,
and you might have
heard the term "data
lake" is use a data lake to kind
of drop all of this raw data,
and then you sort of
transform the data
and rewrite it back
into the data lake,
and you sort of do all
of your batch pipelines
and analytics on that data.
And then when you've
sort of come up
with an interesting data set
that you're ready to serve,
often that's a great set
of data then take and put
into something that's a more
structured store for analytics
like BigQuery, right?
So you might do lots or
raw analytics on your data,
establish some kind
of batch processing,
and then push that
data into BigQuery
for serving and accessing
via your favorite BI
tool of choice.
So this, again-- another very
powerful pattern that we see.
And, you know, the nice
part, again, about the cloud
is we've done this really
nice job of separating compute
from storage.
So you just pay for the
storage that you need,
pay for the compute and the
analytics that you need,
and build these very
sophisticated pipelines.
OK, so if you're also
thinking about hey,
what about all that data
I've still got on premise?
What am I going
to do about that?
How am I going to
leverage the cloud for it,
or how am I going to
get it to the cloud?
So we've got a set of
interesting use cases
and a set of partners that
we work with closely here.
If I want to ingest data, set
of partners to help ingest data,
whether that be structured data
or large-scale batch data, disk
shipping, for example.
We have a set of
partners for that.
Another use case we see is
just doing backup in DR.
So typically, you
might be using, like,
Veritas or storage use.
It's an application that
you're already familiar with.
CloudBerry is something
for the SMB market.
It's an application that
you're already familiar with.
And under the covers, that
will store data into something
like Google Cloud Storage
as the object store.
Also, tiering-- this is another
super common use case we see.
Folks have invested in some
on-premises infrastructure,
but they recognize
they have cold data,
and they don't want to pay for
more infrastructure on premises
to store that cold data.
So using something
like NetApp or EMC,
they're able to use the
management tools that they're
familiar with today, and
establish a cloud archival
tier to store their
data off in the cloud.
So we've got a great
set of partnerships
with a range of
companies here to let
you use the tools that
you're familiar with
and still get the benefits of an
on-premises environment that's
bridged and hybrid
across to the cloud.
And I think that's me.
Dominic.
And we'll do Q&A at
the end, as well.
DOMINIC PREUSS: Yep.
Our goal is to do about
40, 45 minutes of talking,
and then give sufficient
time at the end for you
guys to ask questions.
So stepping over into
the database world,
I wanted to start by
talking about Cloud SQL.
So Cloud SQL is our managed
service for third party RDBMSs.
So today, it supports MySQL.
We are incredibly excited
to announce Postgres support
in Cloud SQL today,
and we'll continue
to add additional
RDBMSs over time.
So what this means is that
it's a fully managed service
that allows us to manage your
instances on your behalf.
So we're running MySQL,
we're doing backups,
we're doing security updates,
updating the minor versions
of the software so that you
don't have to worry about that.
We act as your DBA to
manage that service for you.
We do automatic backups
and handle failover.
So we maintain
failover replicas.
You as the customer
have the option
of running a single instance
or adding a failover
replica for your database.
If you have a failover
replica for your database
and are running in
high-availability mode,
then you have a 99.95%
availability SLA.
One of the things I do
like to point out to people
is that we at Google
very much believe
in putting numbers and
guarantees behind our products.
So you'll see as we go through
this, all of our products
have service-level
agreements that
give your expectations of
the availability you'll
get from that service.
And it's something that we
feel very strongly about.
So what is a common use case
and a common architecture
for Cloud SQL?
One is e-commerce.
So in this particular
scenario, you
will have an
e-commerce application.
It might be running
in App Engine,
it might be running
on Compute Engine.
So this could be WordPress,
it could be Drupal.
You could be running Hybris--
any of one of your various
e-commerce solutions
that requires a MySQL
or Postgres database.
In the background,
because we're running
in high-availability mode,
we have a failover replica
which allows us to failover
in the event of a failure
of the master node.
We also have added
read replicas.
So one of the reasons
to add read replicas
to the architecture is you
want to either shard your reads
and writes.
You might be getting
close to the capacity
that you can put through
your master node,
so you want to start setting
your reads to a read replica
so that you get more capacity
for writes on the master.
Another very common
reason to do this
is your analytics workloads.
So you don't want
your analytics queries
that are coming
from your BI tool,
whether it be Tableau,
Looker, or iCharts,
several of the partners
that we have for Cloud SQL--
you don't want the queries
coming from those dashboards
to interfere with your
customers' experience.
You don't want analytics queries
to stack up and or increase
the latency that your
outside customers are.
So quite often, people
will set up a read replica
and point their BI tools
at this read replica
to make sure that they've
separated their analytics
workloads and their
production workloads.
So that's a very common way that
we see people using Cloud SQL.
Obviously, with
Postgres, very popular
for mobile applications.
So we're expecting
to see an increased
number of mobile applications
running Postgres and using
PostGIS as the Postgres
feature rolls out.
The next one is Cloud Datastore.
So Cloud Datastore is our
managed document database
service.
So if you were building
a mobile or web app that
is consuming and
producing lots of JSON
or your data is in
a document format,
then Cloud Datastore is a
fantastic solution for you.
It's optimized for those
mobile and web scenarios.
It does autoscaling
and autoreplication,
so you can start at zero, just
start throwing data at it,
and it will grow
with your business.
You only pay for what you use.
So you pay for write ops
and read ops and storage,
and you don't pay
for anything else.
You don't have to worry about
provisioning capacity up front.
am I going to have 10 users,
am I going to have
1,000 users, or am I
going to have 10 million users?
Am I going to become Snapchat?
You don't have to worry
about any of those things.
You basically just
throwing data at Datastore
and it'll grow
with your service.
And again, going back to the
service-level agreements,
it comes with a
99.95% availability.
We do offer a regional
version of this,
which is not multi-region.
So Cloud Datastore by
default is multi-region.
If you use our regional
Cloud Datastore,
then you'll get three
nines of availability.
Today, Cloud Datastore has
lots of success stories
in the mobile gaming space.
You've heard many
times about Pokemon Go.
We've talked about Snapchat.
But lots of mobile applications
use Cloud Datastore
as its application database.
So you often have the
application running.
This could be the
player front end
that has all of the [INAUDIBLE]
about an individual player.
All of that data is being
stored in Cloud Datastore.
On the back end, you've got your
world view or the world data,
so where are the players?
What are they doing?
What's going on in the world?
All that information is running
on a different compute stack.
And again, all of
that data is being
stored in Cloud Datastore.
You don't have
multiple databases,
you aren't running
multiple instances.
You're putting all of your data
into a single data store, which
simplifies your architecture
and makes it easy to both deploy
and scale up your application.
On the front end, you're using
Google Cloud Load Balancer.
We don't talk about this as
much as we probably should,
but the Google
Cloud Load Balancer
is actually a fantastic product
because it isn't a single VM
being spun up in your project.
It is a global load balancer
that happens at the edge.
And so what that
means is that you
don't have regional dependencies
on your load balancer,
and it allows you to load
balance across regions.
So in this particular
scenario, this application
may be a GKE cluster
running in multiple regions
all speaking to the same
Cloud Datastore back end.
And you can load balance
globally between those regions
because the Google Cloud Load
Balancer is a global service.
We talked a little
bit about Firebase.
We're very excited to continue
to leverage the amazing work
that the Firebase team
has done, and to provide
a first-rate mobile developer
experience for Google Cloud
Platform.
If you're a mobile developer
coming to Google Cloud
Platform, Firebase is really
that optimized experience
for you to build your
applications on top of.
They do provide a real
time database option.
So this is a managed
mobile database service.
The real strength of
Firebase as a platform
is the number of services
that it provides, but also
the native SDKs.
So they provide an iOS
SDK, an SDK for Android,
an SDK for client-side
JavaScript.
So if you're building
an application
on multiple platforms, Firebase
gives you a unified platform
for building your applications.
The other thing that's very
important where building mobile
is offline access.
So if your customer is using
your application and they are
not connected to the internet--
they might be in a tunnel,
they might be in the subway,
they might be in the middle
of the woods in Yosemite
and they don't have internet
access--
you still have access to all
of your database information
because there's an offline
version of the data.
And then when that mobile
device comes back online,
it handles synchronization
to make sure
that the data on the device
is synced with the data that's
in the cloud.
So a very powerful application
from the Firebase folks.
And again, the
beauty of Firebase
is because you're
building on their SDKs,
your architecture
is very simple.
You have a number
of devices that
have integrated their SDKs
into your application,
and it's all going to
a centralized location
in the back.
A good example here is
Firebase realtime database.
Another good example
is Firebase Analytics.
You might be using Firebase
Analytics integrated
in all of your
apps, and then it's
very easy to export that
data from Firebase Analytics
into BigQuery so that you
can run your ad hoc queries.
So because we have
this tight integration
between the Firebase services
and the Google Cloud Platform
services, it makes it very
easy for you to leverage one,
and then once you need to get
the power of the Google Cloud
Platform, it's trivial to move
your data over and move it
into some of the other Google
Cloud Platform services.
Next is Cloud Bigtable.
So Cloud Bigtable is our managed
analytics database service.
So this is a managed wide
column database service.
We at Google are firmly
committed to the idea
of being the open cloud.
One of the best
examples of this is
that we took our internal
Bigtable technology
and externalized it
to the outside world
as an HBase-compatible
client library.
We wanted the
outside world to be
able to adopt the Bigtable
technology in the easiest way
possible with the least
amount of friction.
And we found that by giving
them an HBase-compatible client
library, it allowed them to
very seamlessly move their HBase
clusters over and copy their
data from one HBase cluster
into ours, and therefore moving
from a self-managed solution
that could be running on
premise or on Compute Engine
VMs onto a fully managed
database service.
The power of Cloud
Bigtable is that it
gives you very low-latency
reads and writes,
so you get single-millisecond
reads and writes, and gives you
very fast table scans
so that you can quickly
scan through your data and
pull out maybe the most
recent version of a metric,
or do these very large table
scans.
Currently, Cloud Bigtable
is a zonal service,
and so it offers you
99.5% availability
for all of your data.
A very common use case that
we see for Cloud Bigtable
Internet of Things, so IoT.
What we often see is that
we have a number of devices
generating information.
From Dave's example earlier, it
might be a Rolls Royce engine
developing telemetry,
sending telemetry back
to your centralized location.
It might be sensors that are
sending back sensor data.
It might be mobile
devices sending back
event data or things that
are happening on the device.
Basically, you
have a large number
of devices generating a large
number of pieces of data
that all need to be pushed
back into Google Cloud Platform
to be analyzed maybe
today, maybe in the future,
depending on what
you're trying to do.
So the way that we do
this consolidation,
and one of the best ways to
get data into the Google Cloud
Platform, is through Pub/Sub.
So Cloud Pub/Sub is our
message queue product.
Similar to our load balancer,
it is a global service.
So if you have mobile devices or
sensors or Rolls Royce engines
around the world that all
need to be able to push back
into a centralized
location, Cloud Pub/Sub
gives you a global service to
be able to push that data back.
You don't have to worry
that that device happens
to be in Asia and your service
is in the United States.
You're just pushing
it into Cloud Pub/Sub,
and you will enter
the Google network
at the closest
possible location,
and that data will be
stored in Cloud Pub/Sub.
We then offer two different
ways of getting the data out
of Cloud Pub/Sub, getting
all those messages
into your system.
So Cloud Dataproc is our managed
open source data processing
platform that supports
MapReduce and SPARC.
So if you have SPARC jobs that
you're running on premise,
you can put them in
the Cloud Dataproc.
Same thing for MapReduce.
You can do this in batch.
You can also do
stream with SPARC,
but most frequently,
we see batch.
The other one is our fully
managed data processing product
which is called
Dataflow, which allows
you to build on Apache, Beam.
So Dataflow is our data
processing framework
that we just pushed
into the Apache project.
It was recently accepted
as a top-level Apache
project called Apache Beam.
And Apache Beam allows you
to build these portable data
processing pipelines, and is
another very common use case.
So once you have these
data processing tools
picking up the data
out of Pub/Sub,
you're dropping them
into Cloud Bigtable.
So Cloud Bigtable then allows
you to analyze the data.
So it really excels
at time series data.
We use it quite a bit
for graph use cases.
And it is very
efficient for writing
lots and lots and lots
of data and then doing
scans across that data.
It also provides mutations, so
you can do asset transactions
at a row level if you need to
do a large number of updates,
as well.
And so until now, the way that
people would analyze that data,
they would go and
run these queries.
We're very excited, as well,
to announce at this conference
the ability for BigQuery
federated queries
to search Bigtable data.
So what this means is you
can write all of your data
into Bigtable.
So if you have a use case that
requires a lot of mutations
or you need single-millisecond
reads and writes
where BigQuery
doesn't meet that need
and you need a database as
opposed to way data warehouse,
you can write all of that
data in the Cloud Bigtable,
and now you can run
your SQL queries
from BigQuery using federated
queries to query the data
inline without copying it or
e-tailing it into BigQuery
in Cloud Bigtable.
So now we've provided
a native SQL interface
for doing SQL queries against
your data in Cloud Bigtable.
The added benefit of
the Cloud Bigtable
federated queries is that any
of our BI tools, or business
intelligence tools, or data
visualization tools that
are integrated with BigQuery
now work on top of Bigtable,
as well.
So if you are using Tableau
or Looker or iCharts
or MicroStrategy-- whatever
your firm happens to use,
you now have compatibility with
your data in Cloud Bigtable.
Cloud Spanner-- so we're
able to spend some time on it
on the keynote today,
and really showed,
kind of, the scale and
the types of things
you could do with Spanner.
It is our managed
relational database service,
so it is a horizontally
scalable relational
database with global consistency
and asset transactions.
And so what this means is that
your data can grow with you.
So if you happen to start
on a smaller data set,
and as you're going
over time, you
don't have to worry about
outgrowing your existing
relational database.
If you're currently
running a sharded MySQL
or manually sharded
Postgres implementation,
then you know the pain that
comes along with doing that,
and Spanner starts to
provide real value to you.
Another example is
high availability.
So if you're running a
master-slave scenario
with any traditional
RDBMS, you have
to accept downtime on
failover for things
like software upgrade,
security patches, maintenance.
Because Spanner
is distributed, we
don't have to worry about that.
You don't have
downtime for upgrades.
We can do all of
the upgrades inline.
You don't have downtime
to do maintenance.
Your service stays up and
is serving your business.
Because of this
architecture and the fact
that it's a fundamentally
different approach
to relational
databases, we can offer
four nines of availability
for our regional instances.
So that's four minutes and 23
seconds of downtime per month.
And with the
multi-regional versions
that we're rolling
out later this year,
you'll get five nines
of availability.
That's 26 seconds
of downtime a month.
So how do people
use Cloud Spanner?
We've been running an
early access program
for over a year with
a number of customers,
and we've already started
to see very strong adoption
from the Cloud Spanner
product in beta.
One of the very common use
cases is global supply chain.
So places that you really
care about global consistency
are financial transactions,
inventory management,
places where being off
by one really matters.
If you have five things and
you try to sell six of them,
then you have an
unhappy customer
and that's a bad
customer experience.
And so Cloud Spanner
provides you a consistent way
of storing that data.
So a common way that we see
this is that in supply chain,
basically Cloud Datastore
access your ledger
for all of your inventory.
You might have an
application, which
is your supply chain,
that is working
with your various
vendors that happened
to be delivering
pieces of your product
and then going
into assembly line.
And then once those
products have been produced,
they go into a separate
inventory system.
So instead of having
multiple data sources where
you store your supply chain
information and your inventory,
you can store them all
into a single database
with a single source of
truth so that you always
have a global view of what's
going on with your inventory
and your supply chain.
Another great thing
about Cloud Spanner
is that it's an application
database that you can also
do analytics on.
And so you can connect
your analytics queries
to Cloud Spanner, to relational
database running SQL.
We've already announced a
number of launch partners
for data visualization
and BI tools.
We'll continue to roll those out
through the rest of the year.
But you can also run
your analytics queries
on top of Cloud Spanner.
And if you need
additional capacity,
you don't have to
create a read replica.
You just make sure that you're
provisioned appropriately
for your compute nodes to
be able to handle that load.
And BigQuery.
So coming back, there's
lots of sessions
at the conference
about BigQuery,
but I want to touch
on it briefly.
Google BigQuery query is our
cloud-native data warehouse.
It's a fully managed
analytics data warehouse.
It gives you tremendous speed.
The thing that we
often talk about
is speed, which is
that you can scan
terabytes of data in seconds.
We also talk about scale.
Just like all of our
serverless applications,
you don't have to
provision capacity upfront.
You don't have to say, I
need a terabyte of storage.
You say, I have data.
Here's my data,
and now I'm going
to start running some queries.
There's very little
upfront work that
has to be done except
defining a schema.
You can start
writing data into it,
you don't have to
provision it, and then
you can just start
running your app queries.
And BigQuery,
again-- big on SLAs.
BigQuery offers a
99.9% availability SLA.
What is a common
reference architecture?
Kind of going back
to our example
before, very similar
architecture-- writing
a bunch of logs data
into Cloud Pub/Sub.
So again, this might
be mobile devices,
it might be IoT devices.
It might be applications
that are generating events.
All those events get written
into the Cloud Pub/Sub.
You process them with the
data processing pipelines
and drop them into BigQuery.
Now over time, you can go back
and run historical queries.
You can see how often are those
events happening over time.
You get auto date
partitioning of your tables
so that you can go back
and run those queries
in an efficient way.
And again, because
it uses that same SQL
and you get that
same interface, you
get the same BI tools like
Tableau, Looker, and iCharts.
Great.
So Dave and I have just
gone through a large number
of products.
Hopefully we have
a managed service
to meet every one
of your use cases.
Obviously, if there
isn't one here,
we have lots of tools to help
you run your own workloads
on Google Cloud
Platform, but we want
to make sure that we
have at least a managed
service for each
of your workloads
so that if you choose to go
to the managed service path,
we have an option for you.
So how do I decide?
So here's a quick
overview of all the things
we've talked about today.
We left out
persistent disk, which
we can talk about, which
is our block source device,
Firebase because it's
just too big a slide.
But effectively, this takes
you through our options.
So if you were
looking for in-memory,
we offer App Engine memcache.
So if you have an App
Engine application that
requires memcache
for caching, we
provide that as a
managed service.
If you're looking for managed
MySQL or managed Postgres--
I'm so happy to be
able to say that now--
you have Cloud SQL for
running your databases.
If you outgrow what you can
do in MySQL or Postgres,
or need the super high
availability that you
can get from Cloud
Spanner, then you
can move up to Cloud Spanner
as your scale-out and highly
available database for your
mission-critical applications.
If you're building a
mobile and web application
and your data is document-based,
then Cloud Datastore
gives you a very easy onboard
to go from zero to petabytes
of scale with that
data structure
and a very easy method for
getting up and running.
Cloud Bigtable is our
analytics database.
So if you have key-value
data or wide column data
that requires lots of
mutations, Cloud Bigtable.
Cloud storage-- another use case
that we don't really talk about
and why I always like to
include it in the slide
is because BigQuery has
federated queries, and the fact
that BigQuery can search
BigQuery columnar data,
it can search G Drive files, but
it can also search GCS files.
So another common pattern is
customers writing Avro files
into a GCS bucket
and then running
BigQuery to run their SQL
queries all over that data.
So unlike some of
the other providers,
we don't think that
that's a separate product,
we just think that that's
a feature of BigQuery.
And we see that pattern
over and over again
as a way for customers to
maintain that data in a GCS
bucket and to run those queries.
So how do I decide?
The magic slide.
Left it for the end.
So people tell me time and time
again, please, just tell me
what product to
use, so I've tried
to take the last
two years of advice
and put it into a
single flow chart.
And what this flowchart says is,
great, is your data structured?
If the answer is no,
then the next question
is do you need mobile SDKs?
If you need a mobile
SDK, then please
use Cloud Storage for Firebase.
If you don't need
mobile SDKs, then you
can use Cloud Storage directly.
All the data goes
into the same place,
it's just two different ways of
getting data into the system.
If your data is structured,
then the question
is is this an
analytics workload?
Are you trying to run analytics?
Is the application
latency-sensitive?
Are you going to run back
over historical data?
If the answer is yes,
then the next question
is do you need updates
or low latency?
So BigQuery offers
you mutations,
but there's a limit as
to how many you can do.
So if you have to do a
high volume of mutations
or you need really
low-latency reads and writes,
then you go to Cloud Bigtable.
If you don't need
either of those,
then you can go to BigQuery,
and BigQuery will provide you
all of the analytics
functions in SQL,
historical, autopartitioning,
and all of the things
that BigQuery does
so amazingly well.
So if you are not
building an application,
an analytics workload, so now
you're in this main part here.
So then the question is
is your data relational?
If your data model is
inherently non-relational,
then the next question is
do you need mobile SDKs?
If you need mobile SDKs and
things like offline access,
then you go to the
Firebase realtime database.
If you don't, and you need
client-side client libraries,
then you go to
Claudie Datastore.
If your data is relational
and the answer is yes,
then the next question is do
you need horizontal scalability?
If you don't need horizontal
scalability or the incredibly
high availability that
comes along with that,
then Cloud SQL, either
MySQL or Postgres,
are going to give you
the best experience
for getting your
application up and running.
Incredibly strong
ecosystem, tools
that integrate with both,
lots of community-- developer
community, developer
knowledge-- around it,
and so it's a great solution
for getting your application up
and running.
If you do need
horizontal scalability,
then you come to
Cloud Spanner, and you
can start looking
at Cloud Spanner
as your horizontally
scalable relational database
so that you know that
when you need the scale
and when you need the
high availability,
it's there for you.
So with that, Dave
and I would like
to open it up for questions.
Last pitch beforehand--
if you thought
that this session
was interesting,
here's some other ones
we highly recommend.
Some of these are today
and tomorrow, some of them
were yesterday.
We are already posting many
of the videos on YouTube,
so I encourage you
to go back and view
some of the other videos
offline if you want.
But this is for GCS--
Selecting the Right Storage
Class for Your Use Case,
Optimizing Cloud SQL
Performance, the Cloud Spanner
101 session, which
was yesterday,
but the video is already
posted, and then Zero to App--
Live-Coding an App
with Firebase and GCP.
All related and also
very good use cases.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
as